hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so like some of you
could have heard last time i was live i
would like to tell you again that that i
will be moving hong kong at the end of
the month so i will go back to france
first where the time zone is gonna be
better so i'm gonna do more lives i'm
gonna do some live trading during the
day and i'm very busy guys actually
right now at the moment so in this video
i will combine a few things i would like
to show you so first as you guys know on
my discord we have some trading games so
i will here show you
the different plays you guys decided to
make and of course there is amc ngme
inside those place so i'm gonna analyze
the price action on those two let's get
into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm gonna start with
amc and jimmy but i will do things a
little bit differently we're gonna check
the reasons so here as you guys know on
discord we have some games where every
player that is a member can play it's a
monthly game where you can play up to
five trades every month and i'm taking
care of aggregating the pnl and you guys
give me the reasons why you got in those
trades and i have a ranking so here i'm
gonna take the first
players
so that i have amc and gme so embarka is
doing a trade on gme and amc so that's
perfect we're gonna analyze
why he got or she got into this trade at
what levels first i see that there is no
target which is good we're gonna start
with amc
so embarka both at 41.16 stop loss 35
all right no target third point and the
reason beyond is a sloping breakout and
a divergence so this is a mcl game stop
this is amc and then the other signal
he's telling me i think we will follow
gamestop's breakout full of sense i
think the same so let's first analyze
amc guys so i'm gonna start on a daily
timeframe i think things are looking
pretty good here guys uh once again we
are for me uh some first i'm gonna give
you quickly my analysis then we're gonna
check and back as reasons to get in my
analysis is that we are in a triangle uh
triangles are usually in force waves as
you guys know um eliot f3 is steadying
that
so to me this is one two three four so
this is a false wave this is a triangle
uh we are close to breakout
above the upper band so everything is
looking pretty nice here to me we are
testing this level for the second time
we had a quite uh nice move up on friday
up four percent so it's looking very uh
nice to me we are converging i think
we're gonna break out this week and
we're gonna have some very nice moves to
come the alternative scenario i prefer
to give it right away is just that the
e-wave is a little bit longer
you know this can happen and we may be
gonna take one more time some energy
here around the 38 levels and then go
for the breakout so this is my
alternative scenario which is bullish as
well now let's analyze and because
reasons to get in this trade so let me
check again so sloping breakout
divergence and gamestop breakout okay so
sloping breakout
so i guess the sloping breakout is
we don't have a sloping breakout on the
daily time frame but let's check if we
have something on the hourly timeframe
maybe okay
okay we do all right i get the trade so
you went there at 41.15 right
okay
and i would have here a sloping breakout
i would do something like this maybe
like this okay
so here if i put a small trend line
let me put it in green okay this is
roughly levels
41.16 41.2 okay so i think this is the
sloping breakout you were talking about
and indeed we have it that would do it
like this it's not a very strong trend
line let's be honest because we have
here you know this long tail candle
that could be taken into account or not
so the strength line is not that obvious
to me but here we had some reactions and
then we broke above i don't see any
volume increase which is always better
for a breakout even on the hourly
timeframe so i'm not sure this breakout
is very powerful but okay this is
bullish now we are talking about the
divergence so divergences guys i remind
you how they look so we're looking for
one of those two either the market
making higher lows and the momentum
going higher the market making higher
lows so it was lower lows and here are
higher lows and the momentum shifting uh
down which means that even in a bearish
environment bears are not able to take
ground so i don't see any lower lows so
i guess it's the other one so i'm trying
to find a moment okay where can it be ah
okay i see it
okay
i'm not sure it's this one you were
talking about but i see one all right so
indeed here we have the market making
higher lows okay
in
a
environment that should be controlled by
bears look at the macd look at the rsi
by the way we had some oversold rsi at
those levels that could give us some
information about a potential rebound
that we had but if i check both
indicators the momentum is going lower
right rsi uh making new low magazine
making new law in the same time the
market made a higher low which means
once again that bears were not able to
take ground when when they when they
should it means that here
if it was bearish we should have a
follow-up on the downside which we
didn't we had a reversal so this is
indeed a
bullish hidden divergence all right it
is this one so well done to spot this
one you are in the trade you are third
on the podium thanks to two trades and
basically your winning trade is amc so
it makes sense to analyze this one and
so yeah i'm positive too on amc let's
check game stop so still m baka you told
us so you bought at 214 all right so
you're slightly negative 1.1 percent
which is fine and you see
divergence nice consolidation
before the move okay let's check them
stop
okay so
i agree we have a nice consolidation
just below the so what happens here let
me first sum up the situation guys daily
timeframe triangle in a potential force
wave here the triangle is a bit
different abcde completed already to me
we have already done one
two this is what i'm telling you guys
for i think one or two months for now it
is what is happening
we are supposed to be in this uh third
of the third so we are not surprised to
see those very high volumes very
impulsive moves that makes total sense
for a third of the third just quickly on
amc i think we are only in the first all
right so let's see what the first wave
is doing but i expect then a small
pullback where if we have the breakout
above 44 there's going to be a buying
opportunity probably around 44. so just
for those who would like maybe to
increase the position not financial
advice but think there would be one more
opportunity even after breakout on gme
things are a bit different we might have
a run-up anytime because it's a third of
a third once again so what i like in
this chart is that we did have an area
of consolidation just below the trend
line so what does it mean it means that
we are building energy how do you can
you check with building energy you go on
the hourly time frame you check the rsi
and you can see that the rsi is not over
both anymore it was overbought uh here
as you can see on the first of november
we still went higher than it was over
both again around 2 30 250. we had this
rejection okay this was a breakout that
didn't hold it's not a fake out the fake
out would have hold and then got
rejected this one didn't hold so just
not a breakout we didn't stay long
enough above 230 to have a valid
breakout and right now we are
consolidating guys uh like i said the
rsi is back to uh normal levels to 50 on
their only time frame so we are building
some energy
same situation i'm not sure we're gonna
do maybe one more move down and then
start again it would be possible then it
would mean that the third is complete
that this is a force it would actually
be
not really making sense we should not go
to low here we should stay above two or
five that's why embarka is giving us a
stop loss at 206
206. so what i like to do in this
situation i like to check the fibs all
right i'm going to hourly time frame
and we are supposed to be in a false
wave you guys know um as per elliott
wave theory that false wave usually go
to the 38.2 retracement of wave 3 but
here the wave 3 is so impulsive so we
can allow a bit more room so if i
measure the third wave and i checked the
38.2 it was 220 okay so 220 could have
been the level we had the buying
reaction for now we are concentrating
around the 50 percent at 2 or 14
and to me if we go to the 200 level it
would not look good so 206 why not i try
to really understand where the 206 is
coming from let me go on the first time
frame
visually it's a level that makes sense i
don't see exactly today with today's
press action y206 would be a level i see
the 50 period moving average on the
hourly timeframe at 205 so maybe 204
would be a stop loss that makes sense
too let's see what's happening here but
like i said if i go back on the daily
timeframe i think it's the best to watch
uh jme price action right now so we have
still another boat rsi but fair enough
we can stay overboard and still making
highs we are building some energy just
below the trend line which is good for
me
and once again i told you i didn't say
that guys but on amc we have results
coming tomorrow uh 8th of november
earnings so this can be a catalyzer that
is going to be watched by many investors
uh let's hope we have a good surprise on
those results and to conclude on gme we
are above the moving averages i mean
guys this is bullish you can see what is
happening here we are just converging
towards the end of this triangle and we
start to see the volatility jumping if i
add the bollinger bands which is a good
indicator of whenever a move is starting
you know i'm pretty sure we are above
exactly we were above already here on
the 1st of november and we are now
basically floating with this upper band
so let's see we have the same thing here
so in august but the difference between
august and now is that
in august the breakup level was at 270
so we were far from it now it's at
tutorial and we are still above the
upper band upper band of the bollinger
bands above the all the moving averages
here we were in the fifth wave you can
see one two three four five we were you
know having here market making higher
highs the momentum going lower you see
so this is a bearish divergence here we
have just the market correcting taking
back some energy we don't make new highs
in this area so we don't have a bearish
divergence we are just to me building
energy for the next move
so i'm positive on gamestop and i think
that if we do break above 230 on the
daily time frame so a close above 230
whenever in the week a very
high run up to the 340 area might happen
very quickly it might be like you know
plus 50
in one day
are we talking about yeah let's plus 30
40 it can be a massive massive move up
so
now quickly i'm gonna analyze anxious
that is number one and kimba number two
so anxious with prague prog so let me
have a look at this one so anxious what
did you do bro you bought at 3 30 no
stop loss okay fair enough nice
consolidation before the move and a
re-test and high short interest so we're
gonna check that
nice consolidation before the move and
re-test okay i agree nice consolidation
here indeed then we have a breakout
above the or a yellow trend line on prog
and re-test indeed well done bro well
done because indeed break out re-test
you both on the re-test i like to do
this type of trades here i don't know if
you have a fixed wave coming or not it's
something i'm trying to analyze with you
guys almost daily it's not easy here
it's to me like 50 50. uh let's see what
can happen but indeed this is a valid uh
trade
i would personally use a stop loss below
270 or three because you can also shift
much lower but anxious didn't use a step
stop loss he's right for now he's not
number one in the ranking he use the
leverage of five bro that's serious
that's all right so you are up 27
very well done in your first trade so
what i think on prog is that indeed we
can reach the seven area it's possible
we're in the fifth wave so let's see as
long as we stay i would say i would have
used the 50
okay let's go on hourly time frame here
we have a nice reaction the 200 period
on the hourly time frame which is at 316
is giving three nice reactions here so i
believe that if we don't break it we can
go higher but if we do break it guys be
careful everything can happen so below
three basically i would turn bearish i
am right now kind of neutral slightly
bullish
and indeed we have a nice synthetic
short interest let me show you that
quickly guys
indeed man
that's serious all right let's check
where it's coming from what do we want
to see something around six seven we
have a five strike okay that the biggest
one is the five strike uh 65 percent of
total shot interest the only thing that
to me is not very uh bullish in terms of
squeeze is the dtc at 30 at open three
all right so the daily volume is much
bigger than every older synthetic short
and short combine so i don't believe
this would be the reason why we actually
squeeze but we still have some gamma
around five and we still have this
potential fifth wave to come once again
the target of the fifth wave is 750 if
it's coming because it's a natural
recent high it's a natural resistance
and if you apply fields like i like to
do guys to one plus three you apply to
the bottom of the force get give you
some level so the one to one is at 680
the one two one six one eight is at nine
so nine is a bit too high to me but uh
680 is very achievable so i think this
is possible okay guys so what else can i
tell you on prog nothing nothing more
guys slightly bullish above 315 we're
good let's see if we can get to six or
seven if we do guys i really believe
it's gonna get sold i wouldn't try to
target higher level that than six or
seven personally on this one if i was
stealing i'm personally out of the strat
i was in i got out around 350 on the
breakout above the moving average so
yeah i'm fine to be out let's see maybe
i will get back in later and last one of
the players of the trades that we have
thank you so much guys for playing it's
very interesting for me to analyze the
reasons why you think uh the mark some
stocks would go up
uh odan because you can take bearish
trades as well so kimbap uh with avdl so
kim batting was uh i know she was good
in october but then she didn't finish on
the podium but let's analyze her play so
avdl long company news okay and the
other signal is okay so company news
avdl alright
so i'm gonna do ta personally okay
let's see to me you are just below the
breakout area so i would personally
be careful around this level because we
might say rejection but the good thing
is that we are testing it for the third
time in one month so this is a nice
consolidation just below the breakout
area which is uh bullish which is
positive we are above the moving
averages 20 50 to 100 on the daily
timeframe which is bullish
so we might very well see a breakout
company news maybe we're gonna have some
earnings coming so avdl when are the
earnings coming okay 8th of november
ok i know what you mean so you're
betting on good results just before the
breakout full of sense it's a risky game
but i like it i'm trying to do it
sometimes as well
sometimes it's you know working
sometimes not but it's a very fair play
uh which we will follow and i really do
hope that you have your breakout himba
but i understand the trade so let's see
what happens here so thank you very much
guys for playing once again for now we
have around 15 players so it's not a lot
i would invite you guys to come and play
more for those who are on discord for
those who are not i will make the game
free in the free area uh probably in a
few weeks month once we start to get
everything
uh working well and all the players used
to that i'm also thinking about making
another type of game that i will show
you guys later it's basically going to
be different teams and you know the ones
that are having uh the best results are
qualified for next week the other ones
are out and we're gonna you know every
player would invest like ten dollars i
mean i would put this money for you guys
because you already members on my
discord so it makes sense that i
redistribute some of this money and then
we're gonna build a big prize that the
winner will get so it's gonna be very
exciting i will let you know about
everything that is happening there thank
you again for watching this video and if
you did enjoy it please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to frau i see you guys